[Music]
[Applause]
and
he is mr college basketball and uh
it's great to bring in the emmy and
golden globe winning actor
jim parsons good morning jim surprise
wow yeah yeah yeah oh it's nice to see
you
it's great to see you where would
winning the celebrity bracket challenge
rank among all the great awards honors
that you have
middle lower okay all right
i mean i don't know what i think i
always ask this every year i don't
remember
we don't get anything no yeah respect
well okay and when's the last time you
had respect jim i mean we're giving you
respect
i don't respect myself i mean these are
this was just
you know this was darts at a wall
i mean unless this represents divine
intervention on some part that i'm this
high of the ranking
well you did play god on broadway that's
true
i am connected yes you are what is your
uh
philosophy here in filling out your
brackets
um i uh
i well this year it was i ran across an
article it was like look out for these
upset
i thought you know what that's a great
place to start
okay all right and i picked a couple of
those and then um
and then i let the rest fall into place
as it were
well houston native though you obviously
have the houston cougars winning it all
right
no i didn't which was uh
well i don't know if it's a grave error
yet but i believe isn't that the
illinois bracket
uh yes you have illinois yeah you have
illinois winning it all
yeah which is not going to happen no
it's not no that's
an impossibility well that's why i
figured we'd have you on this week
because next week we
won't have any use for it
what is the coolest award you do have
the love of todd fritzy's
no you can't put that on a mantel jim
you don't want to put that on a mantle
jim
the love of fritzing no my i was i meant
my own todd here at home
oh your husband my my bad i thought
about talking about fritzy
but that's ridiculous i'm not so stupid
come on i don't know i you know
it's my birthday today todd todd you did
not know it was jim's birthday yes he
did
i should have mentioned it to you as the
host of the show but i didn't know
you didn't i wish them a happy birthday
as part of my pitch to
let him know why today would be the best
day to have him on this week
that's basically akin to throwing me on
but it's a different jim parsons
i mean what else don't you tell him
happy birthday thank you so that my
reward is
that i'm i've made it i got i've
been blessed with how many times am i
gonna have to word that before it's not
a negative let's try it again
you know it's like big bang you get
another take here jim so thin
ready three two one i'm so happy to
begin adding up the days that will total
to my 49th year
this is was wonderful
it is though it really is you know but
you don't look any older
do you want to look older oh um
i mean i'm not doing anything to to try
and look
old i mean like i'm not like you know i
didn't pick smoking back up again
yeah but i i don't know if you because
you look
the same yeah well i know i don't it's
it's that you can't the lighting in here
is
it's bad the the lion the lighting is
bad it's bad
i'm sorry this is you can't say that on
cbs you didn't do that on big bang
i have been in a hole away from
all the normal things for so long i
don't know what's right and what's wrong
anymore
i don't know what it takes to to be on
air somewhere
anymore recap the last year if you can
um well this time last year i actually
had
covered we both did and uh so that was
not a great celebration
although i still had a cocktail i'll be
quite frank with you
um best part of that day uh and then
i don't know and then i slowly worked my
way back up into
feeling less um and dark and scared
about everything
that's sort of embarrassing to admit but
honestly i reflect on like before about
three months ago and i'm like
oh my god i had the darkest view of the
world
uh i was just freaked out was hollywood
shut down for the most part the last
year
well a lot of it was but
you'd be surprised at how many things
are working and how many things they're
making and
and the ways they go about it we're
producing one show uh on fox right now
call me cat it's called with with mayam
and
they are they went through their whole
season and i mean
we watched uh feed from it here in new
york like we couldn't be there
and it was it was really well done
and the the way that they could jump
through hoops whatever the masks and the
shields and the feeds
to faraway places i was really impressed
um
but it it looks like a headache i guess
you sort of get used to it but
we're talking to uh the popular jim
parsons emmy and golden globe winning
actor and he's uh celebrating his
birthday today
i just read this story about you were
you auditioned for the office
yes but what role did you audition for i
don't remember it was either
jim or dwight
which which which tells you a lot of
exactly why i wasn't right for it
there wasn't a role that i was a ringer
for i was he could do this one
or he could do that one but i don't even
know i but it was
it was one of those because i knew i i
didn't know well but i knew
rayne wilson and i knew john krasinski
and i think that's why i can't remember
who it was because i knew that whatever
part it was somebody that i
sort of vaguely knew got it but that's
one of those where you want to get the
part
but then is there then but then is there
part of you that knows
i'm i'm might not be the best person for
this part
oh yeah every time i mean almost every
time i've been very fortunate with that
or i'm just very honest with myself but
did you know you were the right person
for big bang theory yeah okay i
knew well i didn't know what they would
think but i knew that i felt that i
would be
in the final mix like i felt that way
about it with the office
and this just shows how stupid i am
about hollywood
i thought what a dumb idea for a show it
was if we wanted to
in america we would have done it already
we don't need bbc
copy or whatever it was on um
but i was wrong i have no foresight with
things like that apparently but if you
got that role then you don't get sheldon
and big bad that's exactly right the
whole everything
for a reason yeah what are you working
on now
well i mean there's a movie i've been
working on that
we're hoping to shoot in the fall at
some point so that would really be the
next thing i have kept doing
uh voice overs for young sheldon they
sent me in fact you might be able to see
it sort of
see that tall box there yeah it's a
whole
voice kit they they mailed me this so
they can record me
um and so every few weeks i come up here
and record a few episodes of that
wow gotta be exhausting there jim you
you walk upstairs yeah and you get to
keep it for a little while and i go i go
back
and take a nap and then i got up for a
cocktail and then it's time to go back
to bed again
is this is this the highlight of your
day like what do you do after this
uh today i'll eat right after this and
then i will go to
uh best buy actually i'm gonna walk over
to best buy and i need a cord to hook up
todd bought me a turntable
for my birthday and the speaker that
came with it didn't come with a wire
that
hooked them up so i need to go get a 3.5
millimeter
i have no idea what kind of albums do
you have
well i just started in fact i didn't i
thought i was going to get
we were kind of doing a renovation thing
so i thought well when that's over i'll
get a turntable but i bought my nephew
one for his birthday back in january and
i got really excited about the idea so i
started buying vinyl
and i had four albums arrived this past
week but i had no turntable
and then i didn't know i was getting one
but right now i have four
i have the pixies do little i have pj
harvey stories from the city stories
from the sea
i have uh the smiths the queen is dead
and the war on drugs a live album uh
live drugs
okay that's my collection four
what what constitutes a collection like
what's the number that that
i don't know if four's a collection jim
no well
well i mean it's what i have right now
dan and i can play them
so you know well no you can't the
speaker's not oh that's right
well within a few hours from now i think
i'll be able to go
but don't you have somebody who can go
get you this wire
aren't you you're like a big-time
celebrity what do you mean
no no we don't we don't roll like that
for the most part
you don't roll like that no we do our
own laundry
we wash our own dishes well i i do that
too
but
but i don't mind going to get this are
you kidding any chance any
opportunity to get out fully masked even
yeah
i'm kind of excited about it and i'm
very excited about the turntable so i
want full
ownership of it which includes buying
this stray cord
will you disguise your voice when you go
to best buy
no that sounds really exhausting also i
have a mask on
well i know but if somebody hears your
voice yeah
sometimes that happens sometimes that
hap but it's been funny
to to suddenly be in a masked world
you know when you're used to sometimes
people recognizing you it's very odd
yeah do you remember do you remember the
uh fight slam
at u of h yeah yeah how old i was young
i wasn't there but yeah
i remember it how old were you with five
slam pajama
i don't know was i eight seven
what year was it that was 82-83
oh i was 9 into 10 9 or 10.
and you remember that well my
mother went to u of h and
maybe even around that time because she
was going back for some uh
advanced courses in in education uh
teaching um and then and then hakeem
came
directly out of college to the rockets
which was a big deal because
everybody was so excited because he had
already been in in houston
from that so and they talked a lot about
and a lot of it i learned
probably when clyde came to when drexler
came to the rockets in
for the championship uh years uh because
they were back together again and that
was a big story
hey i watched the flight attendant with
uh your
a former co-star she's greater than that
it's her and rosie perez and yeah but
kaylee is
really really like it's it's a little
jarring because you see big bang and
then you see her in flight attendant
where
she's a mess and it's
uh i didn't know that she had that those
abilities because i hadn't seen that
before but oh she's a hot mess
yes yes hot mess easy yes but at that
that turned out to be a really good show
he's great in that and they got a lot of
attention it's really
that's really exciting well
congratulations on your temporary first
place
uh right now because it won't come soon
won't it
yes it will but not our love for you
thank you
and uh tell todd i said hello and happy
birthday
and i i hope you get to do something
really really exciting today besides
going to best
buy keep up the puns gentlemen thank you
jim
okay that's uh the popular jim parsons
emmy gold globe winning actor big time
star